gotta have a suggestions lifestyle we're
at a logo to put it from a sea
from the birds
not really other ways to get food around
here
salmon only comes once here and I gotta
try and every time they come around
[Music]
yeah I love this
you see anything no nothing
absolutely nothing
is that our first net
and we weren't catching anything yeah we
just keep going up over until we get to
the family
pretty much a small window
hopefully we'll get some salmon
I see my boys they're gonna be another
stepping stone for our culture that's
all I am that's what I'm passing down to
my son
it's a little torn up
all right you guys keep an eye on it
and look around when you're coming up
the bank that might be from Grizzlies
you know
[Music]
this is your grandma Christine's cabin
door is still locked
poke
yeah
squirrels came in
and it doesn't bear to be demolished in
here
you're picking stuff up grab a trash bag
been having some tough luck all fall we
haven't really seen very many moves
the story has told me as a kid is
everybody's got a bag that they carry
around with them inside that bag is your
luck
all year you're supposed to work on that
luck and add to it put a little bit in
here and there helping somebody out
paying it forward
but let's get this wood stacked up the
more we do better chance we'll have
it is very important to me to get better
luck because I love hunting and I love
seeing stuff it just gives joy to me and
excitement
I'm already looking nicer boys
we used to play in that place my late
brother came down by himself and he
built this little cash style house
it's kind of like a little Treehouse the
kids like it now yeah that's what my
late brother made right there
this is called the boys club but no
girls have allowed never mind
[Music]
boys come on
let's go get your life jacket
all right boys I feel a lot better about
leaving camp
you know we left it a little better than
what we found it so I feel like you know
we added some good luck to our bag I
feel you know we have a better chance of
seeing something out there now
let's hope and pray we see something on
the way home boys
[Music]